this is the bar i've owned for the last
two years
while serving drinks and socializing is
a pretty great job do you know what the
most frustrating part about it is
when customers leave but forget their
credit card at the bar it's pretty much
a lose-lose situation for everyone
involved
wired has given me one week to figure
out how to stop people from leaving the
bar without taking their credit card
[Music]
we're locked on and it's gone
by the way i'm mark klieb i'm a creative
technologist based in brooklyn new york
i've been building custom arcade
machines for local independent game
developers in 2019
my wife and i opened wonderville a
bushwick-based bar and arcade that's
filled to the brim with those games
there are three main goals i have for
this project one figure out the best
location tracking technology
to install at the exit of the bar two to
be able to determine when someone is
leaving without their credit card
three figure out how to somehow get
their attention and prevent them from
leaving without it
so here's the plan once i determine the
best technology to use
i'm going to install a location sensor
by the door whenever someone opens a tab
i'll trade them some kind of location
tracker then
i'll program the sensor to only go off
when someone tries to leave the bar
with the tracker i know some of you
might be thinking what if someone wants
to go outside to have a cigarette
well we have a backyard they can go out
there instead
finally when the sensor goes off i want
to build some kind of display that does
whatever it needs to do
to stop them dead in their tracks the
first thing i'm going to need to do
is figure out which location tracking
technology is best for this project
[Music]
i've narrowed it down to three different
types of technology gps
bluetooth and rfid let's start by taking
a look at gps
so this is an adafruit feather
microcontroller with a gps
add-on and what this allows me to do is
use
a computer to write code to basically
use this gps to communicate with
a satellite if i receive a transmission
back
i can determine my latitude and
longitude anywhere on the globe
so i plugged in the gps module and i
brought up
some example code from adafruit on
parsing serial data
so i get the time i get the date and
it's accurate right however i'm not
seeing latitude and longitude
because i have fix zero i'm
not getting a fix and that's probably
because
i'm in this windowless box
where i don't have any access
to a satellite so the next step is to go
outside
and see if it works outdoors all right
i've gotta fix 40.41 north
73.55 west we're locked on we'll see if
this works when i bring it inside
still gotta fix and it's gone
i think the gps is only gonna work
outside with a clear path
to the sky as soon as we come inside we
lose the connection
i think we can safely rule out gps as
a tracker for this project now on to
bluetooth
this is another adafruit board this has
a bluetooth module built in so what
we're going to do is program this
to be a bluetooth beacon a device that
emits
a bluetooth signal so i can use a
raspberry pi computer with a bluetooth
module built in
to sense if there are any bluetooth
beacons in the vicinity
i think this can work really well
because we can install the raspberry pi
near the door and if the beacon gets
close it can trigger the sensor
i found some example code to transform
my bluefruit sense into a beacon this
is a valid beacon packet so this is
what's going to be transmitted i'm going
to get the id
the major and minor and the rssi this is
my received
signal strength indicator so i'm going
to need to set up a bluetooth receiver
and take a look at the rssi value to
determine how
far away it is from the receiver
theoretically i should be able to find a
threshold number
where this is right under the doorway
and trigger the display
when it hits that decibel level i've got
my beacon already plugged
in and working i've got my raspberry pi
here
let's run this code and see what happens
so i've already got a beacon working
right
and if i zoom in here you can see the
rssi
is around negative 45
and so it's roughly 12 inches away
the next thing i want to do is plug this
into a battery
and see if i can get a wider range of
signal strength
just so i can determine if this is a
viable solution
all right i'm down here in the arcade
with my mannequin friend manny
he's gonna act as my customer with a
bluetooth beacon tracker
got him attached to a chair with a dolly
i've got a rope that goes all the way up
to my workbench
and we're gonna monitor the signal
strength as i pull him closer
so i'm just gonna tape this beacon and
i'm gonna pop up stairs
and we're gonna check out the rssi okay
so we got manny
as far away as we could possibly go and
we're getting an rssi of about negative
90. far more than we could get in the
booth so let's pull them closer and i'm
just gonna monitor this value and just
see
how it changes 80 negative 80 negative
78 negative 75
negative 77 and we're at
about negative 75. so we're getting
about a change
from right up to the raspberry pi we
were seeing negative 40
all the way across the room negative 90.
so
i can kind of calibrate distance now
using this signal strength value
so bluetooth works this beacon
i can detect when it's close i can
detect when it's far away using the
signal string
what i don't like about it is that it
needs power
so i need to make sure the batteries are
fully charged and whoever's carrying
this around
if this dies i lose track of them so
it isn't great for that reason if it
came down to it bluetooth would work
i could make this work but i want to see
how rfid goes
rfid radio frequency identification
this is pretty ubiquitous uh if you've
ever used an easy pass
those things that are on clothes if you
try to walk out with them
so what i've got here is a sparkfun
simultaneous
rfid tag reader and it's attached to an
arduino uno
microcontroller the rfid reader will
transmit on a certain wavelength and
when a tag is within range it will
receive a small amount of energy from
that wavelength and
transmit back and if it's within the
range of the rfid reader it can trigger
the sensor
this tracker isn't powered this is just
an antenna
and how it works is the rfid reader
transmits radio waves that travel
through the air and can magnetize and
power this to send a small signal
back to the reader that's how we can
identify
where this tracker is so i've got some
example code here that came from the
sparkfun website and then i'm going to
pop open my serial port
and it says press a key to begin
scanning all right
so there's no rfid tags in the vicinity
and because it's five decibels i
probably won't see anything for more
than a few inches
let's see if i can get these both in the
shot at once i have my tag up here
i'm gonna slowly bring it down closer
closer closer closer
and there it is so i can see my tag data
when i'm within
maybe about two inches of the antenna so
unlike bluetooth i don't get a range i
only
see the tag or i don't so we know that
this works from a few inches away
if i wanna extend the distance i'm gonna
have to install an external antenna
and we're done so i've rerouted the
antenna
to go out through this external antenna
which is gigantic but hopefully will
give me the range that i need
let's do a range test i'm going to go
back to my
same example that i just used before
and let's take this
five decibels and you know what let's
just double it we'll see what we get at
10. so i'm gonna upload this code
if five decibels reads from two inches
away
ten decibels should theoretically work
at four inches let's see
how far away this will work i'm already
getting values
right about here
and this is like 18 inches this must be
reading on a logarithmic
curve which means that the higher the
power
the distance will increase
logarithmically rather than linear
let's go back to manny and we'll see if
we can get this to trigger
only when he gets close to the antenna
same thing we did with bluetooth
i've got an rfid tag here we're gonna
stick it on manny
i've installed the antenna on the
ceiling and we're gonna pull manny in
and hopefully when he's under the
antenna
i can track the tag okay we're gonna
start scanning i'm gonna reel manny in
right now we're not seeing anything but
hopefully when he passes
under the antenna we can see the tag
and we got a tag as soon as manny passed
directly under the antenna i got a tag
to show up
so this is still pretty far away but it
will work we'll just have to recalibrate
it when it's above the exit
out of the three i think rfid is the
most promising for this project
the tags are just a piece of paper i can
affix them to something that the person
can wear
or carry with them and it seems to work
from
many different distances so i'm gonna go
with rfid now i just have to refine it
next up
i'm gonna start working on the display
so here's my plan on how i'm gonna get
people's attention when they leave the
bar
this is the door to the bar i'm gonna
install a sign
it's gonna kind of look like a stop sign
that's gonna attach to the door
and it's gonna say close your
tab and i'm gonna line this with led
strips so if they try to leave the rfid
will go
off it'll light up this sign and they'll
see it before they leave
i also want to have a sound component so
i'm going to install speakers
on either side of the door and we're
going to place some sort of alarm
so that they know something is wrong if
they try to leave
okay so i designed this file and my
intention is to cut this out of plywood
on a cnc
machine so i made it in the shape of a
stop sign because it's being cut out of
wood i needed to use a font
where everything would be attached so
that none of the letters would fall
out i'm here with my cnc machine so a
cnc machine is a computer controlled
cutter
i've got a wood router attached to these
motors and i can take the file that i
designed
and it will cut it out of a sheet of
plywood so the router
i'm going to turn it on and it's going
to move on the x
and the y and the z axis it'll look at
my letters it'll cut them out
and then it'll lift off and move to the
next letter and it'll do this in a
couple
passes so it's not too heavy on the
router bit
once the cnc machine finished i sanded
the sign down
cut out some wood strips and glued them
to the back my plan is to attach led
strips to the back of the sign
so the wood strips are there as a place
to affix them it also creates some
distance between the door
and the sign so the lights can
illuminate and finally i added some
diffusion on the front
i don't want people to be able to read
the sign until it lights up so the
diffusion
will help to hide the letters so after
some testing the led strips weren't
really shining as brightly as i would
have hoped and you can't really read the
letters
so instead i'm gonna go with this super
bright led panel
yep this is gonna look a lot better when
it's mounted over the exit it's a little
bit darker but
here's the final display now on to the
speakers
so i wanted to play a really jarring
sound when someone tries to leave the
bar
so i did a little bit of searching
online and i think i found the perfect
one
so i put the siren sound on this mp3
player which is plugged into this
amplifier which is then plugged into
this speaker
so i have the siren playing on a
constant loop but you can't hear it
because the amp is turned off
this means that when someone walks under
the sensor with the rfid
tag all i have to do is program it to
turn on the power
and all right got the display finished
got the speaker set up so now all i have
to do is get everything working together
so i found some code that plays a sound
on a buzzer
when an rfid tag is near so what i did
was i
added an led because i figured if i can
play a sound on a buzzer i can also turn
an led on
i commented these lines out because i
don't need the buzzers anymore
but i added this line of code that just
turns an led
on when it searches and finds a new tab
so if i start scanning
and i bring an rfid tag close
to the antenna i can turn on the led
now that i know that it works i'm going
to replace the led with a power relay so
a power relay is essentially a power
strip
but it has an input for a 5 volt on off
switch
that i can control from the arduino so
similar to how i can turn the led on and
off
i can turn on and off this power strip
so i've plugged my display
and the amp and the speaker all into the
power relay
when the rfid tag gets close to the
antenna
let's see what happens
so i've programmed everything to turn
off after 10 seconds so we don't have a
constant siren going off
this also will reset the code back to
its original state so we can keep
scanning for more tags
next i need to work on how i'm going to
actually hand the rfid tag to a customer
when they open a tab
so i've got these cool snap bracelets
from the 90s and i was thinking i could
attach the rfid tags
to these so i put one on and check this
out
the sensor is no longer recognizing the
tag
next i got these paper wristbands but
these didn't work either
i did a little bit of research and i
think i discovered the problem
we're using ultra high frequencies for
rfid transmission
inside the snap bracelet is a piece of
metal metal interferes a lot with
wireless transmission so if you attach
the rfid tag to this
it's not going to read very well
similarly on the paper bracelet
the human body is mostly made up of
water and watery objects also cause a
lot of interference
so unfortunately neither of these is
going to be a great option so ultimately
the solution that worked
was taking a little bit of foam and
creating some distance between the rfid
tag and the paper bracelet this foam is
about an eighth of an inch thick it's
adhesive so it was really easy to attach
and it works perfectly if i was gonna
actually implement this in the bar i'd
probably have to come up with a more
elegant solution
but since tomorrow's my last day working
on this project this will have to do
okay so the installation is pretty much
done all that i needed to put
in the exit are the speakers which i
mounted here the antenna which is right
over the doorway
and the display which is hanging on the
door i had to
find a pathway to outside of the exit so
i could run all the speaker wires the
antenna cable and everything
to this wall where i've got the actual
rfid reader the
power relay the amplifier the ipod and
the power for everything
so now that we're installed all i need
to do is fine tune the range of the
antenna
so that when someone walks toward the
door everything goes off at exactly the
right time
after testing it out i think 15 decibels
is what we're going to go with as far as
the range the sweet spot to trigger the
sensor is right about here
just before they walk out the door range
is set
everything's installed i got my
wristband i think it's finally time to
give this a shot
let's go
three three three three three three
three three
so i think it's working pretty well it's
going off at exactly the right time just
before they exit the door
the lights are going on the sounds going
on and
you know it works exactly as i would
have hoped so the true test is gonna be
to try this out on someone who doesn't
know what's coming
so there we go i think we can safely say
no one's going to leave the bar and
forget their credit card
overall i'm pretty happy with the amount
i was able to accomplish in just a week
in terms of practicality i'm not sure
this is something i'm gonna install long
term
the alarms are a little jarring and i
don't want it to seem like someone's
shoplifting
but i think it's a cool experiment and i
think the customers are gonna have some
fun with it i had a great time building
this project it was really fun to work
with the different technologies
maybe everything didn't go exactly as
planned but that's part of the process
and part of the fun